in sonic's newest adventure he's headed
to the star fall islands in search of
chaos emeralds with his friend amy and
tails when trouble strikes
suddenly sucking their plane into a
dimensional portal
our bristly hero awakens in a strange
digital world called cyberspace despite
being separated from his friends sonic
miraculously escapes from this alternate
dimension and arrives on kronos one of
the beautiful starfall islands a curious
wilderness full of ancient ruins
strange inhabitants
and sinister enemies our loyal blue
hedgehog must now find his lost friends
explore this exotic world and solve the
mystery of the starfall islands
sonic frontiers expands on what fans
know and love about traditional sonic
games combining linear level gameplay
and open zone platforming into a new
action-filled sonic experience
the world map is bigger than ever giving
sonic more room to run and explore his
surroundings
sonic frontiers offers high speed open
zone gameplay that gives you the freedom
to play the game in the order that best
matches your play style
engage in exhilarating combat with
exciting new enemies solve intriguing
puzzles and complete fun side quests to
help rescue sonic's friends
solving puzzles will reward the player
with items that can increase sonic's
power and defense
reveal hidden parts of the map
and unlock new ways to navigate the
island at fast speeds
scattered around the starfall islands
are cyberspace portals
defeat bosses throughout the island to
earn portal gears that unlock these
stages
you'll need to complete challenges
within each cyberspace stage to earn
vault keys that can be used to unlock
chaos emerald vaults and allow you to
progress further in the game
in sonic frontiers sonic's combat gets
an upgrade making battling enemies more
exciting and fluid than ever before with
an all new skill tree system featuring a
host of new abilities to unlock and
level up you'll have plenty of options
to fight strategically combined dodges
parries
counters and more
if you prefer more straightforward
gameplay check out auto combos where
various attack combos can be executed
with a single button
these modes make it possible for all
sonic fans to easily enjoy the fast and
flexible new combat system
sonic's enhancements don't stop there
he's learned a new ability called cylub
a band of light that mirrors sonic's
tracks
surround enemies items and areas to
uncover different effects and unlock all
the secrets of the starfall islands
get ready to blaze your own trail and
forge a new frontier in sonic frontiers
available november 8th
stay tuned for more details
[Music]
you